until you learn about body Liberation
and body positivity no one would choose
to continue to be fat in a world where
they absolutely hate fat people people
think that I'm glorifying obesity by
spreading this the word and like telling
everybody about this information I trust
me I wouldn't recommend anybody be fat
in this world it is horrible it is so
traumatizing it is so isolating people
are evil they are cruel Strangers think
it's okay to tell you on the bus you're
fat you should lose weight you're
disgusting like it's nonstop and that
leads to people isolating themselves and
like seeking Comfort through food I like
this argument this seems to be the most
honest argument of all the fat phobia
you know sympathy seeking groups out
there- which is yeah no one would choose
this but it's nevertheless incumbent on
people to work on them